翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
「うがいと手洗い」というのは
もっとも基本的な衛生習慣って
言われてますけれども
皆さんは うがいを毎日していますか？
はい
（笑）
うがいをしているという方は
一日 何回されているでしょうか？
１回でしょうか？ ２回でしょうか？
それとも３回以上でしょうか？
もっとも ここで言う「うがい」というのは
歯磨きの後に口をすすぐ
「クチュクチュうがい」のことではなくて
喉の奥まで水を入れて乱流を起こす ―
そして喉をしっかり洗う
あの「ガラガラうがい」のことです
日本では幼稚園の頃から
うがいを教えられていますので
「風邪の予防にうがい」というのは
当たり前のことになっていますが
世界を見渡すと
決して そうではありません
日本でうがい薬を作っている
メーカーの社長さんが
販売拡張のためにアメリカに行きました
そして いろいろな所で
うがいの説明をするんですが
「あんな下品な音がすること
とても私たちにはできない」って言われて
うがい薬は さっぱり
売れなかったんだそうです
アメリカに限らず
お隣の中国や韓国でも
そしてヨーロッパの国々でも
「風邪の予防にうがいをする」という
発想は ほとんどないようです
うがいは 日本独自の
ユニークな衛生習慣ということで
果たして それが本当に
風邪の予防に有効なのかどうか
世界の文献を調べてみましたが
その有効性を証明した論文は
見当たりませんでした
「エビデンスがない
ならば自分たちで作ろう」というわけで
うがいの風邪予防効果を検証する
世界初の臨床試験を行うことにしました
そのやり方は こうです
日本全国18か所で 390人の
ボランティアの方の協力を得ました
その390人の方を
３つのグループに分けます
１つは 水でうがいをするグループ
１つは ヨード液でうがいをするグループ
そして３つ目は
とくに うがいをしないグループです
この３つのグループに分かれるんですが
参加者が自分の好きなグループを
選ぶわけではありません
くじ引きをしてもらいます
くじ引きといっても
実際は封筒を引くんですが
その封筒を広げると
割り付けが書かれています
この割り付け コンピューターで
乱数を発生して作りましたので
封筒を順番に引いても
ランダムになるんですけれども
この研究では 参加者に自分で
封筒を引いてもらいました
つまり「自分の運命は自分で決める」
という一種の演出なわけです
で このようなランダム割り付けは
３つのグループの間で背景因子
すなわち日頃の衛生習慣ですとか
健康意識ですとか
そういったものを均一にする
そのための科学的な方策です
３つのグループのうち
うがいをする２つのグループには
うがいのやり方も指定しました
少量 20㏄ ぐらいのお水
もしくは薄めたヨード液を口に含み
クチュクチュクチュクチュと
うがいをやります
これ１回目
そして２回目は喉の奥まで入れて
ガラガラガラっていう
この「ガラガラうがい」を
やっていただきます
そして３回目は２回目と同じように
喉の奥まで水を入れて
「ガラガラうがい」を
しっかり やってもらいます
この３回で１クールです
この１クールのうがいを
一日に３回以上
そして それを２か月に渡って
やってもらいました
うがいのやり方には
いろいろな流儀があると思いますが
ここは科学研究ですから
やり方を一通りに決めます
そして全員の参加者に
２か月間に渡って記録をつけてもらいました
「うがい日記」です
うがい日記には 風邪に関する
いろいろな症状が列記されていて
そのそれぞれを
「なし・軽い・中くらい・重い」の
４段階で評価してもらいます
これを一日に１回 寝る前に
その日一日を振り返って書いてもらいます
これを２か月やってもらいます
最終的には３つのグループの間で
風邪を引いた人の割合を比べるわけですが
風邪を引いたかどうかは
自分で判断するわけではありません
この風邪［うがい］日記の中の
どの症状と どの症状が組み合わさって
それがどのくらい悪くなって何日続いたか
こういうことをあらかじめ
事前に決めておいて
そして風邪［うがい］日記に入力して
自動的に判定するわけです
これもですね
科学的に判断する ―
できるだけ客観的な判定をするという
一つの方策です
さあ 結果はどうだったでしょうか？
これがメインの結果です
横軸は うがいを始めてからの日数
縦軸は風邪を引いた人の割合です
うがいをとくにしないグループは
黒い線のようになっていまして
２か月間で およそ
40％の人が風邪を引きました
ところが 水でうがいをしますと
青い線のように
割合にして36％ 減ります
多変量解析で背景因子を揃えると
40％の減少というふうに計算されます
一方 ヨード液でうがいをすると
どうでしょう？
赤い線のようになります
なぜか うがいをしないグループと
あまり変わりませんでした
風邪を引いた場合の
症状についても比較してみました
水うがいをしたグループでは
風邪の症状がいくらか軽くなるという
傾向も認められました
では なぜ水でうがいをすると
風邪を引きにくくなるのでしょうか？
風邪のウイルスが
うがいで洗い流されたのでしょうか？
うーん
風邪のウイルスというのは
喉の細胞のレセプターにくっついて
わりと早く細胞の中に入ってしまいますので
一日に２回や３回うがいをやったぐらいで
これが除去されるとは
ちょっと考えにくいですね
じゃあ なぜでしょうか？
ウイルスの感染を助けるプロテアーゼ
一種の酵素ですけれども
これは口の中に たまたま入ってきた
ある種の細菌が作ったり
あるいは空気中の
埃の中にも あったりしますが
このプロテアーゼ
これでしたらタンパク質ですから
うがいによって 比較的 容易に
除去することができます
ウイルスの感染を助ける物質を
洗い流したんじゃないかというふうに
我々は考えています
ではヨード液は なぜ
あまり効果がなかったのでしょうか？
ヨード液は非常に強力な消毒薬です
確かに 風邪の原因となるウイルスを
やっつけることができますが
口の中に住みついていて
微生物世界の秩序を保っている細菌たち
これを「常在細菌叢」って言いますけれども
この正常な細菌叢
これもヨード液によって
根こそぎ やっつけてしまいます
そのため 口の中は
丸裸の状態になってしまって
かえって感染に弱くなったのかもしれません
もっとも我々の研究は
「実際にやってみたら こうだった」
ということを証明する研究であるので
メカニズムのことまでは説明できません
よって そちらの方は
他の研究者に お任せすることにします
ところで
日本では 風邪の医療費
これが年間およそ５千億円です
で その他に
市販の風邪薬のマーケットが
年間およそ１千億円です
もし世の中の人が
しっかりと うがいをしてくれたら
これらの経費は かなり節約できそうですね
経済的な面だけでなく
労力の損失という面でも
うがいは貢献しそうです
それでは ここで実際に
うがいをやってみましょう
（笑）
色のついた ―
皆さんにね 見やすいために
色のついたお水で やりますけれども
これは水道の水で全然構いません
60cc ぐらい入れます
そして口に含みます
（クチュクチュうがい）
（ガラガラうがい）
３回目は今と同じことを
もう１回だけやります
簡単ですね
うがいをすると口の中が
スッキリするだけでなく
風邪の予防にも役立ちます
今日 このお話をお聞きになった方は
世界のお友達に
ぜひ うがいを勧めてみてください
「健康は毎日のうがいから」
これが今日のテイクホームメッセージです
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）